>>> COME IN, SIR.
>> THANK YOU, DOCTOR.
>> IT'S MY WIFE.
>> WHAT'S WRONG WITH HER?
>> SHE'S A BUMMER.
>> IN THE 19th CENTURY DARK,
COLD, SEASIDE TOWN COMES THE
STORY OF AN UNLIKELY CONNECTION.
>> SHE'S MEDICALLY UPSET.
>> WHAT CAN WE DO DOCTOR?
>> SHE NEEDS SEAGULL SOUNDS,
GRAY HAIR AND LONG ROCKY WALKS.
>> SEE YOU IN TWO MONTHS HERE.
>> YOU'RE LEAVING?
>> YES, WITH HER.
>> I'M YOUR FEMALE COMPANION.
>> FROM PORTRAIT OF A LADY ON
FIRE, AMMONITE AND THE FAVORITE
COMES A NEW AWARD-WINNING FILM,
LESBIAN PERIOD DRAMA.
ANOTHER FILM THAT ISN'T AFRAID
TO ASK WILL THESE LESBIANS BE
LESBIANS TOGETHER?
>> HELLO.
>> STARRING TWO STRAIGHT
ACTRESSES WHO DARE TO NOT WEAR
MAKE-UP.
12 LINES OF DIALOGUE, TWO AND A
HALF HOUR RUN TIME.
>> IT'S A ROCK IN THE BASKET.
THE GRAY ONE'S THE BEST.
>> I'M SCARED OF WATER.
>> THAT IS WHY I PICK ROCKS
ALONE.
>> FEATURING ACADEMY AWARD
WINNING GLANCE CHOREOGRAPHY AND
BEST SUPPORTING ACTRESS NOMINEE
THE WIND AND THE ONE ACTUAL
LESBIAN ACTRESS AS STONE CALLED
X.
>> HEY, I'M REX.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> OH, YEAH, WE WERE TOGETHER
FOR TWO YEARS.
BUT THE SEX WAS SO BAD WE BROKE
UP EVEN THOUGH THERE'S NOT
ANOTHER LESBIAN FOR FIVE WHOLE
COUNTRIES.
>> SURE.
>> SAYS LESBIAN'S MONTHLY, I
MEAN, I'M GOING TO SEE IT.
>> LET ME GUESS.
SHE TOOK YOU TO PICK UP ROCKS?
GUESS WHERE SHE LEARNED THAT
ONE.
>> SADLY ENOUGH.
>> WITNESS THE WORLD'S SADDEST
FLIRTING.
>> SHE DIED BEFORE I WAS BORN.
>> AND WATCH IN HEATED
ANTICIPATION AS THEY ROUND ALL
THE BASES LIKE GRAZING FINGERS,
WASHING CARROTS AND FAST
AGGRESSIVE THIS.
IN A VIEW SAYS, "THEY SAID I SAW
THEIR BACKS, WHICH MADE ME THINK
OF THE FRONT WHERE THE BOOBS
ARE."
AND OF COURSE THERE'S A DRAWING
SCENE.
>> MAY I DRAW YOU?
>> YES.
>> AND MAY I DRAW YOU DRAWING
HER?
>> YES.
>> TWO HOURS OF EXCRUCIATING
LOOKS.
>> I FEEL SOMETHING.
>> I DO, TOO.
>> ALL BUILDING UP TO A SEX
SCENE SO GRAPHIC, YOU'LL THINK,
"OH RIGHT, A MAN DIRECTED THIS."
>> HEY, GAL.
>> IT'S 1840.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S BEEN
INVENTED YESTERDAY.
>> INCORRECT --
>> LESBIAN PERIOD DRAMA, YOU GET
ONE A YEAR.
MAKE THE MOST OF IT.
[